bonjour et bienvenue à tous qui nous
rejoignaient sur public sénat bienvenue
également à tous ceux qui sont dans
cette salle c'est à dire notamment
quelques 150 apprentis venus de toutes
les régions de france et également des
apprentis venus d'allemagne
et si nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
c'est donc pour cette journée qui est
organisé chaque année au sénat les
rencontres sénatoriales de
l'apprentissage
onzième du nom avec cette tonalité
particulière et vous le verrez dans le
débat qui va suivre qu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui d'accueillir un certain
nombre d'apprentis allemand ici au sénat
pour comparer les expériences à
puisqu'on dit beaucoup que la culture de
l'apprentissage très ancrée en allemagne
pourrait peut-être inspiré aussi ce que
nous faisons les expériences que nous
vivons en france à nous en débattrons
dans quelques instants les enjeux de
l'apprentissage en regardant en
comparant les expériences mais tout de
suite pour ouvrir ces onzièmes
rencontres et bien je passe la parole à
madame muguette dini sénatrice du rhône
et présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat madame dit
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général de l'assemblée
permanente de la des chambres de métiers
chers collègues chers amis chers jeunes
apprentis allemands et français
lorsque le président du sénat gérard
larcher m'a proposé voici quelques
semaines d'ouvrir ce 11e rencontres
sénatoriales de l'apprentissage
c'est avec grand plaisir que j'ai
accepté cet honneur et la lourde charge
d'être celle qui vous accueillera pour
cette journée particulière
la commission des affaires sociales que
je préside a travaillé à plusieurs
reprises au cours des dernières années
sur les moyens de développer renforcer
valoriser l'apprentissage qui se trouve
à la jonction de deux de nos
préoccupations majeures la jeunesse et
l'emploi
en effet le chômage des jeunes français
reste le plus élevé des pays de l' ocde
et les difficultés la démotivation qui
en résultent pour ces jeunes ne sont pas
acceptés
abl à l'automne dernier le parlement
français a adopté une loi relative à la
formation professionnelle tout au long
de la vie au cours de les âmes de
l'examen de ce texte nous avons pu
concrètement faire progresser
l'apprentissage et s'il est un secteur
où nous devons nous montrer pragmatique
efficace c'est bien celui là
c'est notamment à l'initiative du sénat
que nous avons ouvert la voie à un
renforcement de l'apprentissage au sein
du secteur public qui restait très à la
traîne en oeuvrant ainsi collectivement
pour le développement de l'apprentissage
dont personne ici ne sous-estime
l'apport essentiel qu'il peut constituer
pour l'avenir de notre pays
j'espère que nous parviendrons à lui
donner toute la place qu'il mérite dans
notre système de formation
nous le savons tel n'est malheureusement
pas le cas aujourd'hui
la france affiche des performances
médiocres et ce gâchis d'énergie et de
talent ne peut perdurer
nous devons surtout continuez à nous
employer à changer les mentalités
ce qui n'est pas la chose la plus facile
car l'apprentissage est encore trop
souvent rhdp reçue comme une voie moins
prestigieuse que les cursus généraux et
universitaire je veux le dire ici avec
force car j'en suis intimement convaincu
il y à autant de mérite il y à autant de
noblesse à être un excellent apprentis
qu'un excellente étudiants et les
métiers auxquels l'apprentissage conduit
sont tout aussi nobles pour toutes ces
raisons je m'associe pleinement à
l'initiative heureuse prise par le
président gérard larcher d'apporter son
soutien à ces regards croisés
franco-allemand sur l'apprentissage que
la chambre des métiers de l'artisanat
organise aujourd'hui au sénat car ce que
nous essayons de construire en france ce
que nous sommes déterminés à faire ici
l'allemagne réussit depuis fort
longtemps
bien sûr en allemagne comme en france
l'apprentissage est synonyme de goût du
travail bien fait du sens de l'effort
d'exigence vis-à-vis de soi-même
il faut bien du courage aux jeunes
boulangers pour se lever tous les matins
à 4h il faut de la détermination pour
travailler sur un chantier toute la
journée
il faut de la volonté pour accepter de
respecter chaque jour les mêmes gestes
afin de parvenir à leur maîtrise
parfaite et pourtant de l'autre côté du
rhin l'apprentissage jouit d'une bien
meilleure considération
on le voit dans le nombre de vocations
qu'il suscite
puisque nos amis allemands forment
600000 apprentis par an deux fois plus
que nous ce succès s'explique par rail
et par plusieurs facteurs que nous
aurons le temps d'évoquer précisément
aujourd'hui je retiendrai déjà celui de
la coopération et de la confiance
établie entre les centres de formation
et les entreprises et surtout l'image de
l'apprentissage dans l'opinion publique
allemande qui le tient comme une des
voies de l'excellence professionnelle
si autant de jeunes allemands
choisissent l'apprentissage c'est sans
doute parce qu'ils y trouvent une
reconnaissance qui restent ici trop
faible la valorisation française de
l'intelligence théorique peut se
comprendre mais elle ne se comprend pas
s'il compte vie à dénigrer ou négligés
l'intelligence pratique beaucoup
d'apprentis ont contribué et contribuent
encore à faire connaître le génie de la
france pensons à à gaston lenôtre
apprenti pâtissier formé dans l'eure et
dont le talent et l'inventivité sont
aujourd'hui connus de tous les
cuisiniers du monde
l'apprentissage en allemagne c'est aussi
la garantie d'une formation de qualité
débouchant sur un emploi correctement
rémunérés comment ne pas faire ici un
lien entre la place de l'apprentissage
le niveau des salaires pratiqués
outre-rhin et la puissance exportatrice
de l'industrie allemande
nous devrions en france nous penchaient
plus attentivement sur têt cette
question promouvoir l'apprentissage
ce n'est pas seulement offrir des
débouchés professionnels de qualité à la
jeunesse s'est aussi formé une
main-d'oeuvre indispensable à une
industrie compétitive capable d'offrir
de bons niveaux de rémunération à ses
salariés c'est donc un pari gagnant
gains
ayant un meilleur salaire pour les
futurs salariés ou professionnels et une
main d'oeuvre mieux formés pour les
entreprises un apprentissage attractif
et là aussi nous avons des enseignements
à tirer de la pratique allemande c'est
également un apprentissage qui ne
condamne pas à un niveau professionnel
déterminé mais constitue la première
marche d'une formation qui peut mener au
sommet de la hiérarchie d'une entreprise
les entreprises allemandes regorge de
cadres issus de l'entreprise
ils sont encore trop rares chez nous
quelle opportunité nous aurions là
pourtant de relancer l'ascenseur social
en permettant à d'anciens apprentis
grâce à la formation professionnelle
continue d'accéder aux plus hautes
fonctions d'encadrement et de direction
je crois donc que nous avons beaucoup à
apprendre de nos échanges d'aujourd'hui
et je voudrais remercier sincèrement nos
amis allemands d'être venu jusqu'à nous
au fond c'est notre devoir commun de
préparer ensemble l'avenir de l'europe
et promouvoir cette formation si
exigeante qu'est l'apprentissage est un
moyen de nous en a quitté à chacun
d'entre vous et en particulier aux
jeunes apprentis et aux dix apprentis
allemands et à leurs accompagnateurs
je souhaite pleine réussite dans ses
projets d'avenir et au nom du sénat je
vous assure de notre entier soutien
je vous remercie
merci à vous me ghedini sénatrice du
rhône et présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat regards
croisés franco-allemand sur
l'apprentissage vous avez tracé le cadre
général du débat qui va nous occuper
aujourd'hui et pour lequel nous allons
accueillir à son nombre de personnalités
qui vont éclairer débattre comparer les
situations également des jeunes qui
témoigneront de leur situation alors
merci à ceux qui vont débattre avec vous
dans un instant de nous rejoindre le
sénateur gilbert barbier sénateur du
jura du groupe
rds le groupe radical vice président de
la commission des affaires sociales
voilà vous pouvez rejoindre la tribune
un autre de vos collègues également qui
est présent il ya d'autres sénateurs
présents dans cette salle ils pourront
aussi s'exprimer
tout comme d'ailleurs chacun d'entre
vous parce qu'on essaiera d'avoir un
échange le plus nourri possible jean
claude carle sénateur de haute-savoie
membre de la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication etc
et rapporteur pour avis du budget de
l'enseignement scolaire au sénat alors
je vous le disais vous le soulignez il
ya quelques instants
madame muguette dini lie à un certain
nombre de d'amis allemands qui sont
venus aujourd'hui pour témoigner des
apprentis mais aussi des responsables
qui peuvent nous faire partager leurs
expériences
c'est le cas du docteur stefan bock qui
est directeur de la formation pour la
chambre des métiers de hanovre qui nous
rejoint et puis nous recevons également
stéphane schwartz qui est président de
la chambre des métiers de berlin
monsieur schwartz vous êtes vous mêmes
chefs d'entreprise très impliqués dans
ces questions d'apprentissage vous nous
direz comment vous vivez cela en
allemagne en ce moment les responsables
des chambres de métiers sont également
là bien sûr puisqu'ils sont les
partenaires très fidèle de ces
rencontres de l'apprentissage
jean pierre bechler qui est artisan
boulanger à colmar vice président de la
chambre des métiers d'alsace et de la
commission des formations au sein de
l'apc m qui nous rejoint voilà
ne bute et pas sur l'estrade
jean-patrick farrugia directeur de la
formation et de l'emploi à l'apc m puis
je vous le disais deux jeunes apprentis
patrick nasa qui est apprenti en
allemagne a dû rennes très exactement
voilà rejoignez-nous patrick et qui
parle bien français donc y aura pas de
problème et nicolas rousseau qui est
apprenti en charente-maritime allons zac
je crois c'est ça non mais voilà bah
vous vous présenterez tout à l'heure et
vous nous donnerez votre expérience
voilà alors pour cadrer ce débat vous
donner quelques repères madame dini vous
en donniez quelques uns tout à l'heure
mais sur ce que représente
l'apprentissage en france ce que vous
attendez aussi de ces échanges parce que
comparaison n'est pas forcément raison
peut pas forcément transposer un modèle
sur un autre on va demander à alain
griset président de l'assemblée
permanente des chambres de métiers de
bien vouloir donner quelques éléments
qui vont peut-être pouvoir ensuite vous
donner matière à réagir et aller plus
loin dans le débat alain griset
président de la chambre de l'assemblée
des chambres de métiers
merci bien madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président de la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat de berlin je suis
directeur de la formation de la chambre
de métiers de manoeuvre mesdames
messieurs les présidents de chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat
mesdames messieurs les apprentis
français et allemand mesdames et
messieurs nous fêtons cette année les
11e rencontres sénatoriales de
l'apprentissage
je profite de l'occasion qui m'est
donnée pour remercier très sincèrement
le sénat et son président monsieur
gérard larcher pour l'effort constant
qui a été conduit se poursuit en faveur
de l'apprentissage
cette année grâce aux thèmes que nous
avons retenu en commun nous avons lu
nous avons voulu porter un regard croisé
sur l'apprentissage en allemagne et en
france
je suis particulièrement heureux que
nous ayons choisi d'associer la france l
allemagne à ces rencontres
d'autant plus que la france l allemagne
au niveau de l'artisanat ont depuis de
longues années entretenu des relations
nombreuses et fournis et que dans
quelques semaines
a bordeaux nous organiserons les
rencontres franco allemande des chambres
de métiers et de l'artisanat depuis de
longues années
l'allemagne est donné en exemple dans
l'apprentissage
al'inverse en france l'apprentissage a
été longtemps mal aimé dans notre
système éducatif pendant de longues
années
cette voie trop souvent été présenté
comme une orientation par défaut ni
valorisé ni valorisante pour les jeunes
et leurs familles pour autant
l'artisanat français a toujours cru en
apprentissage et était le seul secteur
économique à le sauvegarder à le
développer
quand il était le plus contesté depuis
30 ans l'artisanat est le promoteur de
sa renaissance nous avons ainsi accompli
une véritable reconquête des lèvres les
des lettres de noblesse de
l'apprentissage en france et nous
continuons de poursuivre nos efforts
pour qu'avec l'appui des pouvoirs
publics
l'apprentissage continue d'évoluer pour
répondre toujours mieux aux attentes des
entreprises et des apprentis
l'apprentissage peut désormais s'appuyer
sur une image positive et constitue une
filière à part entière il est apprécié
des entreprises mais également des
jeunes de leurs parents pour ses
résultats en termes d'insertion
professionnelle mais aussi du regard que
ces jeunes filles et ces jeunes hommes
portent sur eux
le soutien des pouvoirs publics a été
déterminant au cours de ces dernières
années notamment celui appuyé d'un
ministre du travail
aujourd'hui président du sénat les
chiffres de l'apprentissage en france
portent témoignage de ces évolutions
ils sont en constante progression certes
les allemands sont encore plus nombreux
à opter pour cette filière mais c'est
comparer ces chiffres c'est comparer
deux systèmes qui sont différents même
s'ils utilisent la même pédagogie et les
mêmes mots l'important dans les deux cas
c'est que des familles et des jeunes
fassent confiance à des entreprises pour
les former et quand réponses des
entreprises s'engagent pour former des
jeunes pour autant il faut reconnaître
que nous avons encore des progrès à
réaliser pour obtenir les mêmes
résultats que nos collègues allemands
vont le préciser nos travaux de ce matin
la table ronde va nous aider à porter le
regard croisé qui nous aidera à une
meilleure approche des deux systèmes
nous pourrons ainsi mesurer les écarts
et imaginer des pistes pour construire à
partir de nos différences pour que
demain la formation de nos jeunes par
l'apprentissage avance et soit encore
plus efficace pour la performance de nos
entreprises et de la compétitivité de
l'europe
je vous remercie de votre attention si
vous permettez maintenant place aux
débats
merci beaucoup alain griset on va
peut-être entrer dans le vif du sujet
avant de comparer un peu les systèmes
par un élément d'actualité
c'est vrai que l'apprentissage comme je
dirais l'ensemble de l'économie a bien
sûr subi je les imagine une crise
économique et donc que don ne pouvait
pas l'apprentissage était forcément
aussi concerné par ce qui s'est passé en
termes de disponibilité des entreprises
alors je voudrais d'abord demandé je
sais pas peut-être que monsieur bechler
peut nous dire un mot là-dessus parce
que c'est un élément d'actualité très
récent hier le président de la
république a annoncé un certain nombre
un balai dans le cadre du balayage des
mesures exceptionnelles qui avaient été
prises pour faire face à la crise
économique que les mesures spécifiques
destinées à maintenir et à encourager
l'apprentissage serait prolongée c'est
pas le cas de toutes les mesures d'
aides aux entreprises
je voudrais savoir ce que vous en pensez
et si effectivement comment
l'apprentissage à traverser la crise
économique que nous venons de vivre
merci bonjour à tout le monde
je répondrai j'essaierai d'être co
naturellement voilà soyez cours à chaque
fois qu'elle sera là
on demandera aussi à nos amis allemands
comment ils ont vécu cette période du
point de vue de l'apprentissage en
allemagne parce qu'on a beaucoup dit
qu'à un moment donné à l'entreprise elle
prenait plus d'apprentis alors je dirais
trois choses la première est
effectivement c'est vrai qu'ils avaient
une réticence au niveau des chefs
d'entreprise dans cette période de crise
mais j'ai toujours dit et j'espère que
tous mes collègues tiend tiendront le
même langage la crise elle est là
aujourd'hui mais à la sortie de la crise
il nous faudra de nouveau une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée et s'ils ont la forme
pas aujourd'hui on ne l'aura pas demain
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose et le président crise
elle a bien dit l'apprentissage est
quand même une voix et une issue qui va
donner un emploi parce que beaucoup
enfin dans beaucoup de deux réunions et
de et de collectivités où je suis on
parle toujours d'orientation et
d'apprentissage mais pour moi
l'orientation et l'apprentissage et
réussissent ils débouchent sur un emploi
et l'apprentissage
elle peut être fière de 2,2 ce slogan là
car 80% de nos apprentis trouvent un
emploi à l'issue de l'apprentissage
ça c'est la deuxième chose est la
troisième chose ben si vous vous l'avait
dit et je le dis aussi si le président
nicolas sarkozy a maintenu les aides et
dans l'orientation de la formation de
l'apprentissage c'est qui c'est comme
nous tous que c'est quand même l'issue
aujourd'hui et peut-être aussi la
réussite pour maintenir une économie en
bonne santé
donc c est dense et un coup de pouce
cette entreprise mais ceux qui vont
s'engager les apprentis c'est vrai je
les ai entendus comme vous que tout les
toutes les aides n'ont pas été relevés
des laitues et c'est d'ailleurs très
clairement un signal qui est donné
j'ai vu le président le 8 à colmar 1 je
ne savais pas encore sinon je l'aurais
félicité voilà monsieur je parte on va
rentrer plus en détail dans quelques
minutes sur cette culture allemande de
l'apprentissage mais d'abord peut-être
la même question d'actualité qu'à votre
cas votre collègue vous même vous
ce chef d'entreprise je crois que vous
dirigez une entreprise possédant le
nettoyage
donc j'imagine dans la région de berlin
notamment dans toute l'allemagne avec
1200 salariés
est ce qu'à un moment donné avec la
crise économique que l'allemagne a subi
comme la france de façon extrêmement
difficile vous avez eu l'impression qu'
il pouvait y avoir une remise en cause
de ce système de formation et
d'insertion professionnelle pour les
jeunes de la part des entreprises ont
fait en fait à faire une expérience
étonnante et très intéressante au moment
de la crise parce que on avait peur en
allemagne que le système d'apprentissage
va va subir des problèmes à cause de la
crise mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les entreprises étaient dans la majorité
très intelligent puisqu'il savait que
dans certains jours la crise sera finie
et on a besoin de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
c'est pour ça que on a pas on en avait
pas un problème que les entreprises
n'embauchent et plus d'aidé
des apprentis on avait notre problème
c'était que on a déjà un grand problème
démographique
c'est à dire en allemagne je crois c'est
beaucoup plus grave en allemagne qu'en
france ce problème on a chaque année en
a moins d'élèves qui sortent des écoles
alors on avait certaines branches dans
l'artisanat qui cherchaient
désespérément jeu des apprentis ont ils
pouvaient pas trouver des apprentis
c'est une situation absolument
absolument absolument nouvelle en
allemagne qu'on ne trouvait pas des
apprentis pour certaines professions
donc c'est pas tant les entreprises qui
ne voulait plus recrutées dans
l'atlantique les entreprises qui pour
certaines certains métiers nous avons
plus d'apprentis voilà c'est ça et donc
vous nous direz comment y répondre
comment expliquez-vous on a entendu les
propos liminaires tout à l'heure de
madame d'une idée d'alain griset comment
expliquez-vous en allemagne vous même au
travers de votre expérience
cette profondeur de la culture de
l'apprentissage le fait que
l'apprentissage soit vraiment inscrit
dans notre système économique et
culturel finalement bon je crois en
allemagne on a une très longue tradition
d'apprentissage on peut expliquer sa
part une tradition qui est dax depuis
plusieurs centaines d'années
si vous voulez l'apprentissage dans
l'artisanat
mais je crois aussi que c'est une
expérience où les jeunes en allemagne
notamment les entreprises savent bien
que que c'est un système qui est très
efficace parce que ce système garantit
une formation théorique parce que c'est
on appelle le système
en allemagne on appelle ça le système
dual ça consiste en deux facteurs si
vous voulez la ccc
l'éducation en classe mais de l'autre
côté vous avez la formation dont la dans
la vie réelle des entreprises
c'est-à-dire les les apprentis dès le
début ils sont en contact avec les
clients avec les fournisseurs avec les
les collègues
donc ils sont dans une situation réelle
de la vie professionnelle et je crois
que c'est ça qui fait ce système
tellement efficace que après ils ont
réussi leur l'information ils ont
vraiment une
ils représentent une main d'oeuvre
vraiment qualifier qu'il est très très
utile pour les entreprises
de l'autre côté les parents puisque je
sais bien qu'il y a des différentes
entre comme on dire la réputation de
l'apprentissage parmi les parents en
allemagne des parents disent que si si
si le jeune veut faire un apprentissage
dans l'artisanat par exemple c'est très
bon s'est très réputé ça une image
excellent souvent les gens font une
formation dont dans la présence de
l'apprentissage dans l'artisanat et
après ils font des études
l'un n'exclut pas l'autre et je crois
que ça c'est aussi une clé pour
comprendre la situation en allemagne que
la réputation parmi les parents de
l'information dans l'artisanat est très
très très très élevé c'est très très
bonne image
ça n'est pas considéré comme étant une
voix mineurs comme un simple lettre
en france pas du tout - maintenant mais
en tout cas on disait tout à l'heure ça
les points d'accord et donc cet
apprentissage et est considéré comme
étant nous quelque chose de tout à fait
valorisant pour les jeunes
quelle que soit la formation qu'ils ont
c'est à dire que dans le système
scolaire à un moment donné le contact
avec l'entreprise est beaucoup plus
répandu qu'il ne l'est par exemple chez
nous sinon voila voila c'est pour ça
qu'on qu'on dit toujours que c'est une
formation très très pratique et qui
répond à mon avis d'une façon idéale aux
exigences des entreprises
alors peut-être votre collègue le dr
stefan bock qui est directeur de la
formation de la chambre des métiers de
hanovre peut-être vous pouvez vous nous
apporter quelques précisions pour qu'on
comprenne bien et on verra ensuite
quelles sont les différences avec notre
situation française mais je crois que la
question de l'apprentissage sans entrer
dans le détail technique mais pour bien
comprendre le système dans sa globalité
il y a une très forte présence de
l'apprentissage des l'orientation des
jeunes et d'autre part une très forte
implication des entreprises peut être
plus forte que ce que nous connaissons
chez nous en france dans votre système
d'apprentissage allemand nous avons déjà
écouté que de partenaires c'est l'école
professionnelle et ce sont les
entreprises et les entreprises cherchent
déjà plus tôt c'est à dire pendant la
période scolaire les jeunes gens et le
propose des stages et cetera pour
trouver des jeunes gens et pour les
intégrer dans leur entreprise
et ça veut dire s'engage beaucoup parce
qu'il ya nous avons déjà écouté il ya
beaucoup plus de problèmes avec les
à cause de la développement
démographique et à cause des cônes et
des problèmes avec des connaissances
générales avec des compétences
personnelles de trouver assez de jeunes
gens pour les entreprises c'est un grand
défi en allemagne c'est pourquoi il faut
travailler ensemble et très plutôt être
plutôt entre la les écoles élémentaires
et les entreprises et habré et ont fait
un contre un entre l'entreprise et les
jeunes gens et les chambres de métiers
examinant les entreprises si les cils et
c'est à dire si le teint un entrepreneur
accueille un apprenti pour la première
fois à partir de quel âge un apprenti
peut-il être accueillis à avoir ce
premier contact avec l'entreprise
le premier contient peut-être avec 14
ans oui pendant la période scolaire et
ont fait le contrat plus tard elle
vers 17 7 ans peut-être vingt ans c'est
différent mais dès 14 ans ça peut
commencer
alors chez nous on verra mais ya
peut-être des réticences à démarrer si
jeune et et après ce sont des
conseilleurs de la chambre des métiers
qui sont dans les entreprises sur place
et le constate si le si l'entreprise est
en mesure de former et on accompagne le
l'apprentissage et on peut appeler les
conseilleurs en cas de conflit et cetera
ou si on a des problèmes à cause de
mauvais résultats et c c'est à dire il y
a on accompagne les entreprises jusqu'à
jusqu'aux examens il y à peu près
combien alors en france on dit à 400000
apprentis à peu près dont un peu moins
de 200 mille formés par les entreprises
artisanales
quel est le chiffre en allemagne sur le
nombre d'apprentis
ce sont environ un million un million et
demi à peu près d'apprentis au total un
million six cent 1600000 oui mais toutes
branches confondues pas seulement dans
l'artisanat l'industrie également
peut-être un mot de jean patrick
farrugia qu'elle vous paraît s'être
monsieur farrugia au travers de ce qu'on
vient d'entendre sur ces témoignages
ce qui distingue particulièrement et qui
peut expliquer le fait que en france
nous ne sommes pas au même niveau en ce
qui concerne le développement de
l'apprentissage est peut-être pas la
même approche finalement je dirai
simplement quelques points le premier
c'est que en france traditionnellement
même si nous avons une pratique ancienne
de l'apprentissage
on privilégie les formations et
intellectuels les formations qui
ne sont pas tournés vers la pratique et
qui sont tournés vers l'abstraction
ce qui fait que le regard qui est porté
en général sur l'apprentissage est
toujours un regard un peu de deuxième
choix par rapport à une voie principale
qui est une voie vers l'abstraction
la deuxième chose par rapport à ce
qu'ont dit nos interlocuteurs c'est que
le système en entier de l'apprentissage
en allemagne négocié ses objectifs avec
les entreprises en france le système non
pas des pans mai et négocier avec les
conseils régionaux par rapport à des
objectifs que l'on se donne dans les
conseils régionaux et moins par rapport
aux objectifs chiffrés par rapport aux
entreprises ça fait aussi une différence
pas la façon de mettre en oeuvre
l'apprentissage la troisième chose je
crois c'est que compte tenu de cette
approche différente qu'il valorise le
savoir faire pratique on peut pratiquer
en allemagne un travail plus précoce
avec les jeunes par rapport à
l'apprentissage des métiers par rapport
à l'ouverture au choix à la validation
de leur choix c'est à dire si le premier
choix n'est pas validé mais il est
encore temps d'en de changer de métier
d'en faire un autre alors que chez nous
la moyenne des apprentis rentrer plus
tard dans l'apprentissage ce qui
rigidifie un peu les parcours et tout
ceci explique de mon point de vue le
fait qu' on a un développement différent
avec en plus le fait que l'apprentissage
tel qu'il est conçu en allemagne c'est
la voie pour la formation pour entrer en
entreprise toutes entreprises confondues
oui donc que ce soit d'ailleurs pour des
métiers artisanaux que l'on disait dans
l'industrie et aussi pour des formations
plus intellectuel on peut aussi passer
par le par l'apprentissage
alors je voudrais savoir ce qu'en
pensent nos deux parlementaires qui sont
qui sont ici nous sommes donc avec
gilbert barbier et jean claude carle
on vient de voir un peu à la fois la
différence de cultures différentes
approches une place plus décisive des
entreprises dans l'arbitrage en faveur
des entreprises alors qu'il attend en
faveur de l'apprentissage alors qu'en
france on a le le filtre des régions qui
n'est pas négatif parce qu'elle organise
vraiment l'apprentissage mais qui en
même temps introduit une approche
différente
est ce qu'est ce que vous en pensez à ce
que d'après vous il ya des choses à
corriger dans le dans le système
français
monsieur barbier
je crois déjà il faut regarder un petit
peu l'histoire serait on a très
longtemps on a supprimé le certificat
d'études ensuite dans les années 60
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a instauré le
collège unique au collège unique
c'est-à-dire la scolarisation
obligatoire jusqu'à 16 ans qui a conduit
dans ce dans ce collège des jeunes dont
la vocation n'était pas forcément
abstract yves comme celle ci a été dit
et qui pose des problèmes et qui se
retrouvent à 16 ans qui se sont trouvés
parce que les choses quand même changé
ont beaucoup évolué dans une situation
d'échec et c'est une grande difficulté
de pouvoir ensuite récupéré beaucoup de
jeunes à l'époque dans les 30 dernières
années dans cette situation l'autre
problème de qu'il faut pas se cacher et
qui est un véritable problème dans notre
pays c'est le cloisonnement qui toujours
existé qui tend à disparaître mais très
difficilement entre le monde de
l'enseignement l'éducation nationale est
le monde du travail
non j'ai bien que les conseils régionaux
maintenant des riches ça mais il ya
toujours cette réticence que nous avons
en france que le le monde de
l'enseignement tient capter et à garder
ses jeunes pour lui-même et l'ouverture
vers l'entreprise est toujours conseillé
été très longtemps considéré comme
quelque chose
un empiètement sur le domaine de
l'éducation nationale et puis de l'autre
côté faut reconnaître que les
entreprises notamment les petites
entreprises n'ont pas toujours été très
volontaire pour former des apprentis
on le sait très bien parce que la
formation d'un apprenti c'est pas une
rentabilité immédiate c'est du temps
passé et c'est pour cela que nous sommes
très contents que les mesures
financières favorisant l'apprentissage
ont été maintenus parce que beaucoup
d'entreprises si elles n'ont pas ce
petit coup de pouce des pouvoirs publics
pour
engager des apprentis et bien
probablement un certain nombre de noms
seraient donc on a une évolution qui se
fait depuis les dix dernières années il
ya une compréhension il ya un mélange
qui est de plus en plus et il ya une
image qui commence à être retrouvée de
cette valeur des gens qui s'engagent par
la voie de l'apprentissage et je dois
aussi reconnaître que dans ce domaine
les chambres consulaires notamment la
chambre des métiers ou fait d'énormes
progrès et si on se remet vingt ou
trente ans en arrière il y en a qui
connaissent ou on était dans un monde un
petit peu fermé et aujourd'hui à une
ouverture dans ces centres et je pense
que l'apprentissage à l'exemple de nos
amis allemands est en train de
reconquérir la place qu'ils avaient du
temps des compagnons du tour de france
qui bien longtemps parcours et la france
qui était l'élite l'élite deux
intellectuels et manuels à travers le
pays
oui juste un mois avant que jean claude
carle ne s'exprime une réaction de
monsieur schwartz vous avez fait
allusion à deux points l'échec scolaire
est ce que vous avez moins de problèmes
deux jeunes qui sortent du système
scolaire sans rien sans qualification
que nous n'en avons en france où on dit
souvent que le taux de chômage des
jeunes est est l'un des plus importants
d'europe grâce à l'apprentissage
vous avez une meilleure situation en
allemagne et d'autre part le l'autre
éléments mentionnés par le sénateur
gilbert barbier c'est la coupure très
grande entre le monde de l'éducation
nationale et le monde de l'entreprise
est ce qu'elle est moins forte pour
semble-t-il en allemagne de façon très
franche parce que peut-être nous aussi
on a une image un peu idyllique de ce
qui se passe en allemagne comme quoi ce
serait le paradis et voilà bon je suis
pas forcément quoi franchement c'est
c'est très intéressant de voix que quand
on a quand même assez de problèmes en
commun en effet
il y a je peux constater la même
situation qu'eux on a un en allemagne
on a aussi une montre séparer de l'un du
monde réel de la vie professionnelle qui
est qui et le monde d'enseignement ça
c'est un des grands défis pour mettre
notre système d'éducation parce que il
faut commencer très tôt déjà dans l'est
dans les échos ray dans les dents le
dans le système d'éducation nationale il
faut commencer très tôt de de données d
expérience certaine compréhension dont
les jeunes de ce qu'on appelle la vie
professionnelle c'est à dire il faut
commencer déjà à l'âge de 10 ans dans
les classes il faut il faut établir un
contact avec la vie des entreprises
on fait ça on commence à maintenant
parce que notre système d'apprentissage
commence à l'âge de 16 ans de 17 ans et
déjà un peu tard
il faut par exemple donner la
possibilité aux jeunes gens de faire un
stage en stage à l'âge de 13 ans de 14
ans dans les entreprises pour établir
une première compréhension de ce que de
ce que c'est parce dans dans la vie des
entreprises
et ça commence à se faire parce que
quand ça existe au niveau du collège ne
confirmerait les élèves de 3e ont une
semaine un peu de découverte dans les
entreprises et mais on a aussi le
deuxième point on a aussi il faut le
dire franchement 25 % des gens qui
sortent des des écoles sont pas capables
de commencer avec un apprentissage nous
défaire des études 25% et ça c'est
dramatique ça c'est aussi un grand
problème pour pour l'économie nationale
parce que
c'est ça c'est un grand problème pour la
croissance puisque on trouve pas les
gens pour commencer l'apprentissage donc
je crois là on a des niveaux comparables
oui non mais c'est intéressant ce que
vous nous dites parce que
l'apprentissage n'est pas la réponse à
tous les défis aujourd'hui qui se pose
pour le système éducatif même si c'est
bien entendu une voix que vous avez
davantage valorisé jean claude carle
oui je crois que l'apprentissage c'est
la voie de la réussite et moi je
voudrais féliciter les apprentis d'avoir
choisi cette voie pourquoi c'est la voie
de la réussite
parce que si je crois que c'est le
système de formation qui apporte le
mieux cette triple réponse simultanée
que doit apporter un système de
l'information de première c'est une
réponse sociale au projet du jeune ont
fait rien de bien sans passion la
deuxième c'est une réponse aux besoins
de l'économie
et ça notre système éducatif l'avait
très largement oubliée on le voit bien
on fait rentrer un des milliers d'élèves
ou d'étudiants dans des filières qui ne
débouchent sur rien et très souvent la
première porte push un jeune
malheureusement c'est celle de pôle
emploi puis troisième réponse c'est
celle à la diversité des territoires car
la mobilité
elle est souvent dans les discours n est
pas toujours dans les fêtes alors c'est
vrai que ça n'a pas la même ampleur ou
la même réussite en france et en
allemagne les chiffres sont là pour
l'attester en allemagne à peu près 7
deux jeunes sur trois qui suivent le
système dual chez nous c'est un jeune
sur cinq qui se suit la voie de
l'apprentissage en pourquoi on en est
arrivé là ça a déjà été dit à mon sens
trois raisons premièrement un problème
culturel un problème de société
ça a été très bien dit par par monsieur
on est dans une société
la france qui est rare cheese les formes
d'intelligence promet au sommet
l'intelligence abstrait j'ai souvent
l'habitude de le dire cite moi ton
cheese après le bac je te dirai qui tu
es en oubliant les autres formes
d'intelligence intelligence de la main
l'intelligence du geste deuxième raison
c'est qu'on est dans une société et
c'est aussi une différence avec
l'allemagne qui n'aime pas beaucoup
l'entreprise où l'entrepreneur ou
l'entreprenant et en particulier notre
système éducatif
l'entreprise souvent considérée comme
ceux-là titre est souvent cité pas bon
en maths la tira sur le chantier où tu
iras
dans le garage en face et puis troisième
et puis l'entrepreneur s'il réussit on
suspecte de l'avoir fait pas toujours de
la meilleure manière et s'il échoue il
est bon à jeter aux orties la troisième
quand même évolué la troisième raison
c'est vrai ça a été dit aussi c'est que
l'éducation nationale a toujours été
réticente à l'entrée d'autres
partenaires elle considérait que le
savoir la transmission du savoir c'était
sa responsabilité voire monopole alors
c'est vrai c'est en train d'évoluer
c'est en train d'évoluer pourquoi parce
que les lois de décentralisation à qui
on donnait des compétences aux régions
et on voit bien qu'en termes de
formation professionnelle ou
d'apprentissage
ça va dans le bon sens il ya eu la loi
fillon en 2005 à qui a mis dans la loi
quelque chose de très important c'est la
reconnaissance de la communauté
éducative communauté éducative c'est
bien sûr l'éducation nationale c'est ce
sont les familles peut-être un peu
oublié ce sont les collectivités
territoriales et c'est le monde socio
professionnelles épiler loi voquer dont
on l'a sûrement tout à l'heure qui ont
vraiment concrétisé cette communauté
éducatif et qui ont fait passer
c'est pour ça que ça va mieux maintenant
de la formation de compétences séparées
à des compétences véritablement partagée
et notamment la mise en place du plan
régional de formation professionnelle
des jeunes voilà alors ça ce sont des
éléments concrets qui montrent des
évolutions récentes juste je suis sur
ces lois en quoi ça bouleverse un peu la
philosophie le dernier
les dernières avancées législatives en
matière de celle notamment contenues
dans la loi
wauquiez haut sur lequel le sénat a
beaucoup travaillé d'abord l'orientation
on a essayé de faire en sorte que
l'orientation ça ne soit plus une
orientation par échecs successifs mais
une orientation plus choisis que subit
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui et nous
avons souhaité d'ailleurs fédérer à tous
les partenaires de l'information et de
l'orientation car une bonne formation
ça commence par une bonne orientation et
une bonne orientation c'est d'abord une
bonne information
or la bonne information aujourd'hui
c'est elle est réservée à ceux qui à
ceux qui savent ils savent décrypter les
parcours et ceux qui ont les moyens de
pouvoir le décrypter on a amélioré donc
le système d'information on a aussi pris
des mesures pour favoriser
l'apprentissage notamment dans le
secteur public
la france est extrêmement retard nous
avons seulement six mille cinq cents
apprentis dans le secteur public est le
plus mauvais élève
c'est l'état et a pratiquement aucun
contrat d'apprentissage dans les
services de l'état les quelques contres
et quillon c'est dans les collectivités
territoriales et les communes en
particulier donc nous avons supprimer
l'agrément préfectoral pour faciliter
jaillir l'insertion par l'apprentissage
des jeunes dans le dans le secteur
public nous avons pris un certain nombre
d'autres mesures notamment pour
permettre aux apprentis de mieux
préparer un examen
nous avons décidé qu'ils aient un congé
de cinq jours et puis nous avons levé un
frein qui date de 15 ans c'est qu'on
veut bien favoriser l'apprentissage mais
on a des textes concernant la sécurité
qui interdisaient aux jeunes mineurs
donc de moins de 18 ans d'utiliser des
machines dangereuses
alors comment voulez vous qu'un jeune
puisse pratiquer un futur métier
si on lui interdit de se servir des
machines et bien nous avons mis 15 ans
15 ans pour arriver à lever le problème
le décret je crois que laurent wauquiez
le dire à tout à l'heure un toit tomber
je crois que c'était là aussi une
avancée nécessaire et un certain nombre
d'autres mesures sur lequel je pourrai
revenir
oui juste asie monsieur bessler
je voulais juste dire quelque chose
monsieur schmitt l'apd est pas bien dit
il l'a dit mais je le dirai à ma façon
pour avoir pour bien connaître votre
système puisque vous savez d'où je viens
j'ai un pied en france et piech et où un
santon un petit peu ça s'entend mais
serment mais je suis fier ça ça va là
non mais c'est pas du d'ailleurs le
président crise elle le sait bien
non ce que je voulais dire il ya est une
richesse culturelle
voilà il ya une différence fondamentale
et c'est écrit là donc je les ai pas
inventés bien que ça fait dix quinze ans
que je le dis il ya une différence
fondamentale entre la france et
l'allemagne
c'est qu'en france on forme au diplôme
et en allemagne et ses marques et là le
la formation dit exactement comme c'est
écrit un la formation professionnelle et
préparer à une compétence nécessaire à
l'exercice d'un métier et cette phrase
c'est la seule que je voudrais ce soir
que tout le monde retient et c'est
peut-être là la différence parce que un
diplôme c'est quelque chose comme une
carte de crédit que vous avez peut-être
dans votre poche mais ça ne justifie pas
que vous avez des compétences pour faire
un travail
et rappelez-vous six à renaud dutreil
qui était notre ministre de l'artisanat
plusieurs fois je lui ai dit si vous
voulez un bon gâteau c'est pas
l'emballage qui est important mais c'est
ce que vous mettez sur la table le soir
ça fait rire tout le monde
mais c'était quand même la vérité vous y
connaissez en matière de pâtisserie mais
pas sinistré voilà docteur vote sur
juste peut-être un mot pas en
prolongement de ce qu'a dit un instant
monsieur vais-je faire sur le la
valorisation de la compétence comment
s'est organisé en allemagne
comment est-ce qu'on reconnaît la
formation de l'apprenti il ya un diplôme
au bout du compte mais qui sanctionne
une véritable compétence qui est jugé
par l'entreprise par le maître
d'apprentissage comment ça se passe
c'est à dire ce sont les chambres des
métiers qui organise l'examen il y à une
commission où les employeurs les
employés et les enseignants des écoles
professionnelles sont représentés et
hier on développe les devoirs
ensemble ces trains et en examine les
apprentis mais c'est très important je
veux encore recontre en termine
l'apprentissage avec un examen on
travaille plus car dans une entreprise
quelques heures et on commence une
formation continue et en allemagne en
l'artisanat c'est souvent la formation
continue qui termine avec le brevet de
maîtrise et se priver là c'est un billet
pour rentrer dans l'université
ça veut dire les jeunes gens se
développe différents l'un reste à
l'école et fin le bac à l'autre vont
dans les entreprises font
l'apprentissage dans les entreprises
et après quelques et quelques temps
après avec le le premier de matrix ils
ont la même possibilité de faire ses
études à l'université et nous avons un
souvenir le passerelles entre les deux
systèmes je crois que c'est très
important aussi pour l'acceptation de ce
système là en allemagne alors c'est très
important la précision que vous apportez
parce que ça veut dire que une fois
qu'on a son diplôme d'apprenti qu'on a
commencé un métier on a l'équivalent ans
pour reprendre des études théoriques
autrement dit on n'oppose pas le savoir
intellectuel et théorique à
l'apprentissage d'un métier puisque ça
vous donne la même qualification des
parents ça c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant on pourrait transposer ça
en france monsieur barbier
je vous vois un peu dubitatif mais dans
la salle on nous dit quoi et puis on va
demander aux deux oui prochain tout
pêcheur gauffre on peut se former tout
au long de la vie avoir des périodes où
ces fragments c'est vrai qu'ils valence
on sait très bien que aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est d'avoir le baccalauréat
on voulait amener 80% dans les classes
d'âge au baccalauréat on voit ce que ça
donne
comme cela a été souligné c'est à dire
qu'on oriente ensuite l'université des
jeunes qui sont pas forcément destinée
qui ne trouveront pas leur place surtout
qu'ils n'auront pas de débouchés
professionnels dans des filières dont on
sait qu'elles n'aboutissent pas des
places sur le marché alors c'est
effectivement on peut avoir une
équivalence qui permettrait parce qu'en
fait c'est ça à ceux pour les apprentis
c'est de savoir qu'elle est qu'elle peut
être par la suite le parcours
professionnel est de savoir si même si
on a commencé dans cette voie la plus
tard on peut évoluer vers des formations
et accéder à des postes de
responsabilité de création d'entreprise
ou de place de cadres dans les grandes
entreprises malheureusement je crois que
encore et nos entreprises dans ce
domaine là notamment les très grandes
juge les dossiers sur des cv qui sont
des diplômes qui sont dont on n'a pas
jugé de la effectivement de la qualité
donc ce serait une voie intéressante
mais elle me paraît quand même difficile
c'est une révolution intellectuelle à
faire à la fois dans le monde de
l'éducation et à la fois dans le monde
de l'entreprise française motif à rhodia
oui monsieur monsieur le sénateur on est
là justement pour regarder pour regarder
de l'avant puisque nous sommes dans le
lieu où s'élabore la loi pour avoir
cette équivalence en fait une mesure
technique toute simple lordon je ne sais
pas aujourd'hui si les conditions du
dialogue social sont réunis mais il
faudrait avoir des commissions
professionnelle consultative comme elle
existe à l'éducation nationale pour
faire des diplômes comme elle existe
dans certains ministères déjà pour créer
des diplômes de ministère et que nous
pourrions avoir
également dans l'artisanat sur les
titres du secteur des métiers qui
deviendraient des diplômes aujourd'hui
lorsque vous avez un brevet de maîtrise
par exemple il dépend du bon vouloir du
président de l'université de vous
accueillir ou pas dans son cursus brevet
de maîtrise dans quels domaines vins
primés de maîtrise quel qu'il soit
boulangerie peu importe le secteur mais
il dépend du bon vouloir de du président
de l'université de vous accueillir à un
niveau d'entrée qui correspondent à
votre niveau de formation
c'est vrai que si ce titre portel à
marianne que donnent les cp c'est à ce
moment cbc les commissions
professionnelle consultative qui sont
les instances des ministères qui
positionnent et talonne les diplômes par
rapport aux autres
nous aurions la possibilité d'avoir ces
passerelles qui simplifierait beaucoup
dans les deux sens à la fois les gens
qui rejoint une le secteur des métiers
comme les gens qui ayant fait un
première partie de parcours dans les
secteurs de métiers souhaite ensuite
diversifié leur formation monsieur carle
ça vous paraît possible ça con con
introduit cette forme de souplesse et
ses passerelles sur lesquels insistait
notre notre ami allemand et un instant
avant d'entendre les témoignages des
deux apprentis qui l'on pense que comme
carré ça me paraît indispensable mais ça
passe aussi jaillir par une certaine
clarification ou simplification parce
que on l'a dit la formation
professionnelle est pas très développé
dans notre pays
mais on est sans doute le pays qui a le
plus de titres ou de diplômes au monde
avec un certain nombre de diplômes
correspondent je pense en particulier
aux licences professionnelles au masters
plus à la marotte d'un
enseignant-chercheur coke aux besoins de
l'économie
donc oui bien sûr il faut des
passerelles mais je crois qu'il faudra
clarifier ça passe véritablement de par
des compétences partagées entre le monde
professionnel et entre le l'éducation
nationale
voilà alors je reprends ma voix
peut-être pour avoir un peu votre
témoignage sur la manière dont les
choses se passent parce qu'on parle
d'apprentissage puis là vous allez
intervenir dans quelques minutes dans la
salle mais ça voir un peu comment vous
vivez cette expérience la manière dont
vous avez choisi la voie de
l'apprentissage est ce qu'elle donne
aujourd'hui
alors lundi en allemagne l'autre en
france je suis pas parti commencé
peut-être c'est plus facile pour nicolas
rousseau qui est en charente en charente
maritime
vous venez d'où donc très exactement de
jonzac jonzac en charente maritime vous
avez quel âge voilà regardez bien le
micro en face qu'on vous entende bien
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire en
quelques mots comment vous avez été où
vous vous êtes orienté vers
l'apprentissage et où vous en êtes
aujourd'hui mais j'ai fait un collège
normal si j'aime 5e 4e 3e et 4e
un brevet des collèges au bout j'ai
commencé en lycée en seconde générale et
je dois ça m'intéressait pas trop ce que
je faisais au moment d orientation en
fin de troisième et enfin de seconde
générale aussi on ne parlait pas
beaucoup de l'apprentissage on nous
parlait des lycées professionnels
c'est exactement les mêmes diplômes que
l'apprentissage offre un apprentissage
et on a une période d'entreprise on est
ici professionnels ont des stages aussi
un entreprise mais c'est pas comme nous
et on n'en a pas parlé je me suis
intéressé
donc quand vous êtes allé dans un centre
d'orientation de l'éducation nationale
vous avez parlé avec des professionnels
ça c'est pas une voix qui était mise en
avant
non vraiment su dernière qu'on propose
mais vraiment d'accord alors comment ça
s'est passé du coup moi j'avais envie de
travailler
et l'apprentissage mais c'était mieux
pour commencer à travailler tout en
préparant des diplômes parce que
l'apprentissage on peut aller du sap et
au bts en apprentissage
donc moi je trouve pas que c'est
dévalorisant d'un bts on peut aller loin
vous allez voir comment ça s'est il ya
des missions locales des laisser les
fausses ou plus possible vous trouver un
employeur
les centres de formation d'apprentis qui
dépendent des régions j'oublie
il nous orientons trouver un employeur
ont fait les contrats et après on suit
en une perte de cours un stage et après
le récent l'entreprise qu'elle est
l'alternance entre périodes de cours et
périodes en entreprise là vous en êtes
vous aujourd'hui
ambac ces deux semaines de cours de
semaine l'entreprise moitié au dessus
donc deux semaines dans votre entreprise
quelle entreprise vous a recruté en
apprentissage une sous un garage à côté
de côté de cognac enchantement il chine
qu'est ce que vous apprenez le mécanique
automobile
oui hélas vous en ai tous et depuis
combien de temps vous êtes je peux
j'ai fait un bep et j'ai continué sur un
bac es donc vous alternez entre deux
semaines dans l'entreprise de semaine
dans le cfa ou à une formation plus
théorique ils sont éloignés les deux
l'un de l'autre
non parce que tout ce qu'on apprend en
cours même les maths c'est c'est utile
de métier parce que en technologie on a
besoin de formule pour la mécanique et
on doit suivre ça en mathématiques sinon
enfin tout programme vraiment toutes les
matières sont utiles à notre métier
c'est en rapport
c'est en rapport avec ce qu'on apprend
enfin notre métier ça le rend tout de
suite plus intéressant là vous allez
terminer votre première année c'est
saddam anttila je vais terminer la
première année et vise à les abandonner
à la fin de la seconde année l'examen
l'examen qui va vous permettre d'obtenir
le bal un bac professionnel
professionnels comme si vous étiez en
lycée professionnel allemand mais de
manière plus plus alterner
j'aurai les jours et de l'expérience en
sortant avec mon bol qu'on ait quelqu'un
au lycée professionnel mêmes
connaissances théoriques mais il aura
pas l'expérience commençons financer vos
études comment vous en sortez dans la
vie quotidienne alors jeu mais il ya
peut-être des parents derrière bien sûr
le la formation à les rémunérer
en tout chasseur en fonction d'eux
de l'année notre diplôme sûrement
première seconde année voire troisième
de l'âge est bon le l'état de lui une
partie du salaire le le patron aussi je
crois je serai donc vous touchez combien
tous les mois ça c'est un discret remet
aujourd'hui tout le monde à six semaines
760 euros
760 euros qui vous permettent de couvrir
un centre de frais géographiquement les
deux ne sont pas trop éloignés psy je
sais qu'il ya des apprentis qui ont des
problèmes de transport n'ont souvent
appris quand on aime le jeu récupère me
foncer sur faut pas prendre trop de 760
euros ça fait réagir que vous allez plus
que vos collègues je sais pas ouais il a
de la chance semble-t-il
ça dépend la jda en droit ou en excès
voilà ils sont venus ils vont vous en
vouloir peut-être bon donc est-ce que
vous avez une chance aussi on va être
recruté par l'entreprise qui aujourd'hui
vous fait ce contrat ou quand vous aurez
terminé votre parcours
ou est ce que vous pensez à aller voir
ailleurs moi je pense aller voir
ailleurs mais on
c'est possible de ceux recrutés par
l'entreprise au contraire on connaît la
clientèle on est habitués l'entreprise à
son fonctionnement c'est plus pratique
pour le patron lui on à l'ouvrier au
moment de l'embauché il connaît déjà
l'entreprise c'est plus simple pour lui
donc c'est vrai que pour le chef
d'entreprise aussi c'est intéressant de
former quelqu'un qui puisse ensuite
gardé un c'est bien ça me suis aussi
parce que il peut partir mais j'ai parce
que je crois qu'on dit qu'à peu près 90
% des apprentis trouvent un emploi c'est
ça bon c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
pour acheter une entreprise qui s'est
investi dans la formation d'un jeune de
le garder ensuite bien sûr c'est un peu
le but je dirais aussi de
l'apprentissage l'édile ce matin dans le
train aux deux jeunes filles que j'ai
accompagné
vous rigolez pas ce qu'on m'a qu'on me
donne toujours des jeunes filles vous
savez bien débrouillé non mais juste une
réponse pour la salle c'est comment le
prénom nicolas nicolas voilà nicolas 19
ans et il faut savoir qu'il y a dans
l'apprentissage des pourcentage du smic
qui sont donnés donc par six mois ça
veut dire les six premiers mois je crois
25%
ensuite ça évolue et il ya deuxièmement
comme il l'a d'ailleurs dit l'âge aussi
qui est qu'ils jouent au dessus de 18
ans la rénumération est plus importante
mais bon ça c'est pas le problème on est
tous donnés aux jeunes qui sont là ce
que je voulais dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
et les tailleurs les deux jeunes filles
qui sont avec moi sont déjà des jeunes
issus de deux se serra il a aujourd'hui
dans l'artisanat on n'hésite pas à
recruter des jeunes + 2 qui ont plus de
18 ans avec un bac parce qu'ils ont un
niveau naturellement plus élevés et la
compréhension et l'acceptation du de
l'apprentissage du métier est aussi plus
facile pour le chef d'entreprise voilà
moi je suis très fier que des jeunes ont
d'abord fait un peu d études ou ont fait
à bac et je crois qu'en allemagne c'est
aussi un peu comme ça vous êtes très
content d'avoir des jeunes qui ont déjà
un bon niveau
voilà alors moi je voulais le féliciter
nicolas mai
il ya juste un petit truc qui mais je
sais que dans l'automobile parce que
même en alsace j'ai pas réussi à changer
la tendance tu vois c'est que
l'alternance et je dois aussi défendre
des chefs d'entreprise tu le comprends
très bien
l'alternance au bac pro ou pour le
pullback et de 15 jours 15 jours alors
que dans l'artisanat et les trois
semaines en entreprise et une semaine à
l'école et le coup de l'apprenti est le
même alors vous comprenez comme on my
poser la première question sur le non
recrutement en période crise
là vous avez aussi un peu une réponse
quand c'est plus difficile pour
l'entreprise
il préféra avoir un jeune trois semaines
que de ne l'avoir que quinze jours voilà
il ya peut-être effectivement des
aménagements de ces lieux aussi sans
doute à la particularité de certains
métiers
alors votre voisin un collègue sais pas
si vous connaissiez avant dont vous avez
fait connaissance à l'occasion de cette
journée vous êtes patrick nasa où
j'étais au burkina faso je crois que ce
décalage 25 25 ans et vous êtes arrivé
en allemagne en quel âge
en fait mon père il était déjà là bon il
voulait un bon m'amenait même ma mère ne
voulait pas donc un gitan bon d'abord
j'avais commencé les cours d'allemand au
burkina et quand j'ai 18ans banque fim à
la main voilà vous allez rejoindre père
louis qui est en allemagne
vous avez choisi la même voie que votre
camarade la voie d'apprentissage comment
ça s'est passé
en fait chez moi j'ai commencé d'abord
par les coups d'élan et en beauté une
université populaire et d après j'ai
fait le test
bon une série canal main puis je répété
à l'école malgré tout que j'avais fait
la troisième les rues j'ai repris ymbro
pendant pendant pendant pendant la
troisième on a eu un cours concernant
les cris d'une demande de travail avant
ça j'avais fait un stage dans une
entreprise
bon donc quand j'ai terminé la troisième
bon j'ai j'ai posé des demandes dans
l'entreprise mais cette entreprise bon
ils n'auront pas il n'avait pas de toi
en bonne forme et et des radis des
apprentis d'un combat j'étais obligé
c'est en 2005
bon en fait je n'avais toujours pas donc
j'ai commencé à demander dans mon
entourage du bon je connais un monsieur
et il m'a donné un contact dans une
entreprise dont ils ont posé des
conditions qui domine klum je
remplissais donc j'ai posé la demande
ils m'ont invité pour un test
moi j'écris le test on va après ils
m'ont laissé faire une stage pendant
trois semaines et après un bon geste et
le contre pour l'accord donc c'est
vraiment par l'entreprise que les choses
démarrent il fallait ce contrat avec
l'entreprise qu'est ce que c'est comme
entreprise bon c'est une automobile
c'est dans l'automobile oui et d'un fiat
donc assez une grande entreprise n y at
il pas assez bas rien qu'est ce que vous
faites
bon je suis un troisième année pour être
mécatronicien donc un petit peu la même
chose apprenez la mécanique mais nous
dans un petit garage et vous dans un
groupe multinational question c'est tous
et a dû renoncer sans ceinture c'est à
dire c'est en quelle région d'amour
c'est dur on a cité entre aix la
chapelle colin c'est bon j'ai trop brute
s'est souvent marrant c'est plus près de
paris qui est belle
donc on viendra vous voir alors est ce
que comme votre ami ou collègue vous
vous êtes vous avez une rémunération
aussi pendant cette période
d'apprentissage chez un troisième gain
500 euros en première année 1 400 ou 500
euros à la deuxième année mais six mois
si ça ne congrès ça ça ne remplit pas
tes besoins
tu peux toujours posé des demandes et
ils vont accomplir tout on peut obtenir
des soutiens supplémentaires faire la
halle à des sit-in supplémentaires votre
ami me disait votre camarade me disait
15 jours 15 jours 15 jours dans
l'entreprise quinze jours dans une école
où on a une formation un peu plus
générale pour vous comment ça se passe
chez nous c'était à peu près la même
chose
bon mais moi je trouvais pas ça du tout
bien passé un bon quand tu es au garage
et après tu sors qu'un jour quand tu es
au garage et après tu sûr qu'un jour qui
a oublié les trucs que tu avais appris
là-bas ou intenter à l'école vice versa
donc maintenant ils ont mis ça bon je
savais pas trop si le taux s'élève à eau
avec beaucoup de problème donc on a
contacté depuis maintenant 7 et fois
dans la semaine
tu peux être l'un des classes et
mercredi je suis au courage et j'ai dit
bon je repars à l'école et vendredis
chauds car âge et c'est mieux c'est mais
hélas si je n'ai pas compris des trucs à
l'école je me fais explique au garage et
comme si je n'ai pas qu'on progresse
j'aime effet expliqué à l'école en plus
de ça on a des points aussi tu n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre là les
chambres de travail aux idées au point
où on qu'un des cours de soutien aussi
c'est plus souple alors monsieur je
parle c'est pas forcément envoyé le vrai
il ya différents modèles pour le système
dual en allemagne mais le cas normal
c'est que normalement
apprenti fait un à deux jours par
semaine à la classe dans l'école trois
quatre jours dans l'entreprise et ça
c'est bien comme système parce que moi
et moi au garage et est moins à l'école
ben oui comme on est on est là pour
apprendre en bois ya des petits trucs
apprécions rêviez bon à l'école on a
perdu le rythme de travail
regardez toujours leurs actes avec
l'autre finale convient donc vous parler
banc of 5 passes et j'ai pas de langues
africaines dans l'allemand le français
et l'anglais kg après l'école c'est pas
mal hein bravo voilà jean patrick paroux
déjà vous souhaitiez ajouter un mot
j'oubliais on va me sens aux questions
juste apporté deux points simplement
dans ce cas dit notre jeune ami la
première c'est que c'est souvent une
question de financements pour
l'adaptation des rythmes scolaires et
des rythmes d'alternance et que ça se
discute
chez nous avec l'entreprise bien sûr par
rapport à la présence en entreprise mais
également avec les régions le centre de
formation etc
et la deuxième chose parce que dans ce
qu'il a dit me semble quelque chose qui
est passé est peut être un peu inaperçue
mais qui pour nous aujourd'hui de pleine
actualité surtout dans une instance
comme celle ci c'est qu'il a dit qu'il a
été présenté avec une première
entreprise mais que la première
entreprise ne pouvait pas prendre
d'apprentis
c'est tout le sens de l'évolution que
nous voudrions faire avec l'inspection
de l'apprentissage justement qui va
venir en discussion bientôt dans cette
assemblée pour pouvoir mieux ciblées et
accompagner plus précisément les
apprentis dans la greffe qui doit
prendre dans l'entreprise pour que
l'apprentissage soit réussie c'est ce
que nous demandons également
est ce qu'il y à des questions d'autres
témoignages c'est le moment de nourrir
un petit peu le dialogue avec ceux qui
sont en face de vous demandez peut-être
d'autres précisions sur les différences
qu'il peut y avoir entre système
allemand système français avantages
inconvénients ce qui explique aussi ce
plus fort développement de
l'apprentissage en allemagne voilà on
vous donne la parole
micro vous pouvez aussi interpellé vos
camarades pour les apprentis qui sont là
où s'exprimer très librement ou à voir
aussi le témoignage des des chefs
d'entreprises qui sont là et qui
peut-être cru tout ne recrute pas
d'apprentis ce qu'il décide en pense
c'est la première question sur un peu
difficile mais il ya bien quelqu'un qui
va jouer l'apprenti et bien les i madame
la sénatrice on va vous donner un micro
voila voila merci de les uns et les
autres de vous les présenter merci
sashina j'ai donc sénatrice du haut-rhin
je connais bien monsieur béchard
puisqu'on se rencontrent souvent donc
j'ai un fils qui est parti en
apprentissage a fait ainsi ap un bac pro
donc je connais très bien le cursus ma
question est là elle va mon pour des
représentants allemands je voulais
savoir dans l'apprentissage est ce que
les congés donc dans l'année scolaire
sont de cinq semaines aussi ou plus à
partir de 16 ans parce que je trouvais
très très dur pour les jeunes quand ils
partaient à l'apprentissage entre 15 16
ans c'était cette fracture entre entre
les autres élèves et de ne pas pouvoir
exercer certains sports comme les autres
le font et d'avoir vraiment une vie très
changeante donc de passe maintenant que
dans le monde social comme d'autres
élèves alors je voulais savoir comment
ça se passait en allemagne parce que je
sais qu'en suisse jusqu'à l'âge de 20
ans ils ont deux semaines de congés
supplémentaires questions de vie
quotidienne mais qui sont très
importants pour l'acceptation de
l'apprentissage à l'isie monsieur soir
normalement on n'a pas ça en allemagne
on a je crois le canot mal ses six
semaines de congé
même pour les propos pour les gens mais
on a certaines règles de protection pour
les jeunes par exemple le travail
pendant la nuit
parce que dans certaines professions le
boulanger par exemple il travaillait
très tôt le matin donc incertaine
de protection police pour les jeunes qui
ont au moins deux
de 18 ans mais en général idée c'est que
les jeunes s'intègrent dans la vie
professionnelle comme com com com comme
tous les autres comme tous les autres
donc pour les congés c'est la même chose
dr roch vous souhaitez ajouter une
précision sur le temps qui est laissée
aux jeunes pour des congés pour le sport
aussi vous en parlerai dans un moment
alors c'est ça comme ce choix le déjà
dit mais on ne peut pas oublier c'est le
système dual et ça veut dire et c'est à
dire les jeunes gens apprennent les
conditions dont les entreprises pour
réussir pendant le travail pour réussir
pour obtenir un emploi et il y a c'est
pourquoi il y a des exigences d'autres
existent exigences que pour les élèves
et il faut alors il faut équilibrer les
le travail et les
mais c'est la chance aussi pour les pour
les jeunes chance à prendre les
conditions à prendre les déroulements à
prendre les commandes à prendre les
clients et pour acquérir la
qualification et la maturité pour
accéder au marché du travail
qu'est ce que vous en pensez nicolas
comment ça se passe pour vous pour vous
par rapport à vos camarades selon votre
âge vous côtoyez qui sont dans notre
formation sur les congés le sport tout
ce que j'ai sur expo le même train de
vie quand même puisque où on lui courent
c'est fatigant on est debout le boulot
c'est un peu plus comment le soir
contente on a besoin de pratique
physique real on n'a pas forcément envie
d'aller d'aller faire du sport ou même
on n'a pas trop le temps sur 11 heures
quand des c'est vrai que c'est
pas évident parce que les semaines de
course et on finit à 16h30 et dans
l'entreprise 18h30 donc c'est jamais les
mêmes horaires on peut pas prévoir
quelque chose quotidien de toutes les
semaines on peut on peut pas le prévoir
ça change tout le temps
patrick chez nous bon les congés les
apprentis ils peuvent le prendre du même
temps que les élèves go ça c'est la loi
et à prendre concernant le sport les
entreprises n'aiment pas risque de se
blesser réflexion donc les apprentis
memebres on vous encourage pas vraiment
aller vous faire faire du sport
participera pas au mondial de du mois
prochain
l'afrique du sud je suis pas rhodia et
puis juste d'autres questions 28 après
s'il y en a dans la salle juste un mot
quand même parce que c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué pour l'exercice d'un
sport collectif
lorsqu'on est en apprentissage parce
qu'on est en alternance entre une
entreprise et un lieu de formation mais
nous avons quand même depuis cinq ans
maintenant développer une association
qui s'appelle nds a et qui a pour
vocation justement de développer la
pratique du sport dans l'apprentissage
pour ce cas même le sport 1 c'est à la
fois des valeurs d'entreprise
puis la l'agilité et caetera et
aujourd'hui nous avons alors c'est pas
beaucoup par rapport à l'ensemble du
nombre d'apprentis que nous recevons
mais nous avons plus de 3000 jeunes qui
sont inscrits dans la pratique de ce
sport collective
c'est vrai que c'est un peu compliqué à
organiser mais nous poursuivons nos
efforts dans la matière alors une autre
question au premier rang monsieur merci
de vous présenter et jean vincent
boussiquet donc je dirige une entreprise
de charpente couverture et je forme des
apprentis bien évidemment depuis de
longues années
alors on a beaucoup parlé des réticences
et notamment n'a cité l'éducation
nationale mais je crois qu'il ya un
autre facteur important ce sont les
parents parce que les parents et j'ai eu
plusieurs cas comme ça sont souvent
réticents à mettre leurs enfants à
l'apprentissage
d'abord par les risques du métier
c'est que c'est vrai que moi c'est un
métier à risque charpentier couvreur
bon ils sont même un jeune de 16 ans bah
il faut quand même il peut pas rester au
bas de l'échelle donc il faut qu'il
monte sur les sur les édifices etc
alors je crois que ça c'est un frein
qu'il faut il faut essayer quand même de
faire comprendre aux parents qui les
risques sont mesurés qu'il y à des
protections et et on parlait des
machines et tout à l'heure c'est pareil
je crois qu'on le but quand même de
l'apprentissage c'est pas d'envoyer ces
jeunes à des risques démesurés
ça je crois que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument faire passer comme
bcd message qu'il faut le faire passer
quoi oui monsieur charte en allemagne et
on a une perception un peu différente ce
ça parce que en allemagne et c'est
souvent les parents qui donnent le
conseiller à leurs enfants de faire un
apprentissage dans l'artisanat
puisqu'ils savent bien que mm
un apprentissage dans l'artisanat c'est
la meilleure protection contre le
chômage
souvent les jeunes veulent même s'ils
ont un un baccalauréat il veut faire des
études
en les autres font des études et c'est
assez cool c'est c'est bien c'est vous
savez sont les malades qui pousse oui on
sait c'est la dolce vita attendant
l'image de l'imagination des jeunes
tandis que les parents disent tu peux
faire des études après mais il faut
faire quelque chose de solide avant
alors tu fais un apprentissage
donc je crois la perception dont il
était rempli un certain jean claude
carle
oui sans doute un problème d'image qu'il
faut faire évoluer et là les professions
ont bien sûr leur responsabilité mais
aussi il faudrait donner aux jeunes
peut-être plus de perspectives
d'évolution de carrière ça aussi c'est
peut-être pas assez mis en avant et puis
troisième chose il faut aussi que le
jeune ci s'est trompé dans son
orientation puissent pouvoir revenir
pouvoir se reformer qu'on lui donne
l'assurance l'assurance financière 1
qu'il pourra se reconvertir dans une
autre note il ajouta simplement rajouté
à tout à l'heure par rapport à la
pénibilité de l'apprentissage par
rapport à la filière classique
le sénat l'a pris en compte je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure en accordant ça on a mis
dans la loi cinq jours supplémentaires
pour préparer les examens parce que
c'est vrai 1 ils ont un rythme de vie
qui est un peu différent par rapport à
ceux qui suivent la voie la voie
classique
nicolas et patrick est ce que vos
parents vous ont encouragé dans ce que
vous faites vous ont poussée ou pas
vraiment à ce que c'est plutôt à un
choix personnel
mon père tenait ce que j'ai fait une
formation dans n'importe quel métier
quand j'avais commencé le dimanche il a
aussi soutenu de 6 demandé à contacter
ses amis trouver une centre de formation
donc ils ont soutenu et vous là vous
découvrez ce métier ça métier que
j'avais envie d'exercer ou vous dites
parfois je me suis peut-être trompé non
bah en fait un bon pendant contraire la
troisième à travers les stages moi
j'avais
comment trouver mes intérêts mes
intérêts est intéressé dans le domaine
de l'automobile je trouvais que c'était
intéressant et ça me plaisait donc il y
avait opté pour ça nicolas mais moi mes
parents ils m'ont dit c'est vrai qu'il
n'était pas trop d'accord mais pas que
je trouve anormal mais traditionnelle
aux habituels sais pas ce qui est
traditionnel mais je leur ai dit enfin
c'était mon choix quoi que c'est moi qui
voulais le faire c'est pas leur avenir
c'est bien et ils m'ont dit si tu le
fais veulent plus loin essaye d'aller
plus loin possible fait le mais essaye
d'aller le plus loin possible au moins
pour avoir une bonne place et donc là
aujourd'hui ou d aller jusqu où
j'aimerais bien un bts après cependant
bac d'abord après un bts après donc vous
n'avez pas l'impression que vous êtes
trompés non mais ce soit sur la filière
ou sur le métier ces soucis qui est bien
avec l'apprentissage c'est parce que
l'on peut voir si notre métier nous
plaît au peuple qu'on en entreprise sait
pas c'est pas un stage de en mécanique
c'est pas un stage de trois semaines
dans l'année qui va et qui va nous nous
confirmer faut il ya tous les jours dans
un garage failli être l'été l'hiver
s'est pas laissée pas les mêmes
conditions de travail on voit vraiment
commencé tous les jours et vous n'êtes
pas découragé non vous avez vraiment
envie de continuer en bout ce que ça me
plaît ouais d'autres questions ou
témoignages madame
voilà merci de vous lever parce que
comme vous êtes un petit peu loin on
vous verra mieux est de vous présenter
et sabine open secrétaire général de
l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse
en fait donc on a beaucoup entendu sur
la formation professionnelle
apprentissage en allemagne
l'apprentissage en france je voudrais
ajouter un autre aspect qui est celui de
la mobilité est en fait la mobilité
franco allemand puisque l'office franco
allemand pour la jeunesse donc échanges
pas rendre un petit peu plus de deux
cent mille jeunes de 3 à 30 ans de
toutes catégories sociales et parmi ces
deux cent mille jeunes en fait il y a à
peu près douze mille jeunes en formation
professionnelle qui sont échangées donc
ou bien en groupe c'est peut-être
parfois plus facile de partir pour la
première fois à l'étranger en groupe
mais en propose aussi des stages
individuels qui sont à ces demandes et
on développe des outils qui peuvent
faciliter de faire un stage à l'étranger
en elle
en france par métier là c'est le dernier
né c'est un glossaire métiers du livre
dont qui vous explique comment dire les
choses en allemand ou en français parce
qu'il faut on n'est pas obligé de parler
la langue pour partir dans notre pays
c'est plus une préparation à la mobilité
qu'on donne puisque nous savons que en
fait il a pas mal de main d'oeuvre qui
manque en allemagne et en france c'est
la chambre de commerce franco allemand
de paris qui nous le dit c'est des
jeunes qui manquent
qui parle un petit peu plus la langue de
l'autre pays qui connaissent qui connaît
surtout la culture du pays voisins donc
c'est vraiment un investissement pour la
carrière professionnelle et nous sommes
en train de préparer une convention avec
l'apc m qui sera signé en juin
l'appareil pour augmenter en fait les
effectifs des jeunes qui sont échangées
entre les deux pays donc je vous invite
à aller sur le site de l'ofag
www.ifaw.org puisque vous et vous verrez
que en fait ça fait plaisir de découvrir
un autre monde où elle a fait le groupe
la première fois et ça peut vous
rapporter gros pour votre avenir
professionnel
alors enfin justement je sais pas si ça
vous fait avions des rats sus des
apprentis l'idée qu'une circulation
européenne et donc entre la france et
l'allemagne met en place tout à fait à
ça il ya leonardo qui sont des
programmes européens et l'allemagne et
la france dispose donc de ce formidable
instrument ou partenaires qui l'office
franco allemand pour la jeunesse qui a
été fondée par les deux gouvernements en
fait c'est quelque chose qui n'existe
contre la france et l'allemagne donc
professeur nouveau et je crois que là il
sur les dernières dernières années il ya
un peu moins de 2000 milles 800
apprentis des réseaux de ces failles de
chambre de métiers d'apprentis qui ont
fait qu'on pu partir ailleurs en europe
monsieur b clair là dessus sur les
échanges moncaut à louis je mens je
voulais donner un exemple mais
je regarde depuis un bout de temps je
sais pas si elle est si cette personne
est dans cette salle où ciel et dans
l'autre salle alors scellé dans l'autre
salle
elle aurait pu apporter sont rapidement
son témoignage les pales à noël et dans
l'autre salle
c'est une fille allemand de kiel pas
kill kill qui est venu à à wissembourg
elle avait fait un bac ensuite elle a
fait fille au pair en angleterre ils
connaîtront à l'angle je parle bien
français allemand anglais et est là
en arrivant à sarrebruck aller avait vu
un jour qu'elle pouvait faire un stage
dans une pâtisserie à wissembourg
elle est allée dans cette pâtisserie et
voilà elle fait un apprentissage
pâtissière fait son examen là au mois de
juin
donc voilà c'est pas vraiment un
un exemple mais c'est quand même pour
montrer qui a des jeunes qui se
dessinait le voit dans les films aussi
ce dramatique sans que ce soit en groupe
et puis j'ai fait pardon et deuxième
action j'ai fait avec le président de la
chambre de métiers de monsieur lâm de
fribourg 1-1 échanges l'apprenti avec le
cfa de colmar
là aussi nous avons à mener si jeune
dans d'abord on l'avait fait en
pâtisserie et puis maintenant ça se fait
dans d'autres métiers
chaque fois un petit groupe de six qui
vont en allemagne qui vont dans des
entreprises qui reste trois semaines et
après nous en retour on prend
six jeunes deux de ces entreprises là
chez nous en france soit la compléter
les régions se sont beaucoup investis
dans ces échanges ou à ma propre région
la région rhône alpes qui est jumelée
avec le bade wurtemberg il ya des
échanges entre les centres d'apprentis
des deux régions avec des moments des
stages des quelquefois même c'est une
année qui est passé dans l'autre pays
est extrêmement important monsieur vote
le la mobilité des jeunes gens c'est pas
un sapin offres de voyages mais c'est
une question de de qualification et
c'est une chance pour les entreprises se
préparer ou pour une chance pour près
par les salariés pour près par les
apprentis pour le marché aux européennes
pour le marché du travail et européennes
et c'est pourquoi il faut soutenir ses
actions
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que les
jeunes sont beaucoup plus mobile et vous
le prouver aussi dans l'apprentissage
qu'il ya 25 ans il s'est complètement
nécessaire
j'imagine d'ailleurs que parlait cinq
langues dont trois sont des langues
capital direct pôle marchés européens ça
va être un atout dont patrick va pouvoir
profiter au long de sa carrière nicolas
vous souhaitiez thermo ya un mois
environ trois semaines
notre notre cfa il a fait un échange
comme ça on est parti six jours en
allemagne
oldham bourleux
depuis les années 1970 s'il ya une sorte
de contrat des changes entre cfa dans le
même bourré la chambre des métiers de la
charente maritime et ses 8 ans qui en
avait plus et on a eu envie de
recommencer
des personnes qui sont investies
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
parce que les valeurs qui sont restés
vous êtes aguerri il vous regarde vous
pouvez aller remercier ils cfa de saint
germain de lusignan a remis ça en place
et on a pu on est parti six jours il ya
trois semaines en allemagne
vous avez découvert des entreprises dans
les entreprises
on a visité des concessions une chaîne
de montage mercedes on avait l'air comme
entré comment il travaille et comment
quand il était fort mais c'était
vraiment très intéressant y avait il y
avait des ressemblances avec la france
session il y avait beaucoup de
différence c'est pas plus mal que les
avoir vus et comme renault et mercedes
vont travailler ensemble ça vous offre
aussi quelques cas l'auvergne active
ils nous ont quand même proposer des
stages parce que si on voulait revenir
le cfa nous a proposé de nous loger des
entreprises ne sont proposés des stages
mais qui sont très très ouvert
autre question monsieur et puis ensuite
nous ces boules en champs de métiers de
la marne pour revenir rebondir sur la
mobilité et la mobilité de proximité
gérer sera intéressé de savoir comment
gère les centres de formation en
allemagne
surtout ce qui est des placements des
apprentis gestion les internats comment
vous gérer cette problématique qui en ai
une chez nous parce que les parents
seront sont démunis au niveau des moyens
et souvent ils privilégient les laisse
enseignement général parce que
financièrement ils n'ont pas la capacité
pouvoir assumer j'irai des moindres
frais de gestion de leurs jeunes
l'enfant mais on y faisait allusion tout
à l'heure c'est une question importante
vous même vous êtes deux apprentis qui
n'avait pas trop ces problèmes mais
c'est vrai que dans certains endroits
vous dit même que c'est un frein parfois
au choix de l'apprentissage de la part
des parents est-ce que vous souhaiter à
vous pouvez apporter une précision là
dessus pour l'épauler pour les internats
par exemple le nombre n'est pas très
grand parce que normalement si enfin si
on commence l'apprentissage
on le fait tout près de de la maison des
parents
donc c'est seulement pendant certaines
périodes
il faut se déplacer pour faire un stage
dans notre région de l'allemagne au pot
faire ce qu'on appelle hubert triplé
jasper johns et si une partie de la
formation qui se fait dans des écoles
spécialisées
là par exemple la chambre des métiers de
berlin elle a un internat un même
impossibilité de logements pour les
jeunes gens qui est organisé par nous
mêmes est qui et qui est financée d'une
partie de la chambre et d'une partie de
la main publique pas par le ministère
est aussi pas par les jeunes donc les
jeunes quand il vient quand des vivres
là bas ils doivent payer bouge pas de
deux euros cinquante par jour c'est pas
beaucoup mais il faut aussi donc tous
viennent une financement si vous voulez
de des traités des trois pattes et des
chambres de l'an ii de la main public et
des jeunes gens mais vous dites que de
façon générale et une certaine proximité
entre les centres de formation les
entreprises où travaillent les jeunes la
famille et donc il n'y aurait pas en
allemagne ce frein qui est parfois un
obstacle majeur qui étaient parents
décident tu ne feras pas d'apprentissage
parce que ça me coûterait trop cher au
fond c'est ça que vous nous dites ça
c'est ce que je crois ça c'est pas un
problème je crois c'est bien accepter
que le temps de d'apprentissage c'est
bien l'investissement des jeunes aussi
parce que
comme j'ai déjà dit c'est c'est la
protection la plus efficace pour un
propos les jeunes contre le chômage
et alors il a remis de la rémunération
pendant l'apprentissage c'est pas
exceptionnel
ces 500 euros ça dépend aussi des
métiers il ya certes un métier où on
commença à 1000 euros
il ya d'autres métiers par exemple les
coiffeurs ça commence à trois cents
seulement
mais tous les jeunes qui commencent
d'apprentissage ils comprennent ça comme
un investissement dans leur propre pour
les propre avenir alors ça c'est pas
vraiment un frein si vous voulez pour
commencer commencer un apprentissage
monsieur vote vous souhaitez ajouter une
précision pigeon patrick ce système là
que les entreprises pays les salaires
les courses les cotisations sociales les
frais d'examen et cetera c'est une des
raisons pour l'acceptation du système en
allemagne parce que pour le contribuable
allemand
le système est économique oui et c'est
très important et mais ça fonctionne et
c'est une raison de la culture le
système en allemagne jean-patrick rhodia
oui allez-y l'affronter juste une
précision dix ans selon les dernières
études que nous avons fait on se
rencontre en france que la france n'a
pas la même densité que l'allemagne de
population donc on a des zones en france
où il ya beaucoup moins de population
qu'en allemagne on se rend compte que
lorsqu'il faut plus d'une heure entre le
déplacement entre l'entreprise de
centres de formation ou le logement
une vraie difficulté d'accès à
l'apprentissage et nous espérons
travailler dans le cadre du grand
emprunt pour voir comment essayer
d'apporter des solutions à ces logements
de proximité pour des jeunes majeurs
parce que lorsque les jeunes sont ne
sont pas majeurs il ya encore plus de
difficultés pour l'heure leur
accompagnement au quotidien
d'autant que les transports scolaires ou
même pour des apprentis départementaux
c'est plutôt en train de diminuer que de
se densifier êtes un autre sujet
monsieur carle
c'est vrai que la mobilité de proximité
c'est un vrai problème et c'est ce que
j'ai appelé tout à l'heure la troisième
réponse que doit porter un système
d'information c'est la réponse de la
diversité des des territoires et
aujourd'hui qu'on le veuille ou non la
l'orientation se fait souvent par défaut
et en fonction de l'offre de formation
ont choisi de rentrer dans telle ou
telle filière parce qu'il ya à côté un
lycée professionnel un centre de
formation qu'il qu'il le fait en arrive
quelquefois des situations aberrantes
gelé vécu moi j'ai dû fermer le lycée
hôtelier de chamonix parce que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies et ont
continué à former des jeunes à
l'hôtellerie dans deux départements plus
loin à 300 km vous n'êtes pas faire 300
km des jeunes pour venir dans une
entreprise et ça ça ne peut passer que
par un partenariat entre le monde
professionnel et le système éducatif et
c'est ce que nous avons voulu mettre
dans le texte wauquiez à travers le plan
régional des formations inquiets de la
compétence des régions que les
professions soit partenaire de ce plan
est qu un leurre leur signature et
valeurs d'engagement s'il ya pas ça ça
marchera pas une dernière question
monsieur oui steve intello donc
directeurs d'éducation pour la région
alsace
en fait ce ne sont pas des questions
trois témoignages pour donner une touche
très positive encore le premier c'est le
premier témoignage c'est que on a réussi
très récemment sa date de masse dès mars
dernier à obtenir des chambres d'acide
et des caisses d'assurance allemandes
qu'elles puissent considérer donc un
apprenti allemand qui va passer une
période en france qu'elle puisse donc
considérer cette période comme but comme
assurée par la casse allemande puisque
nous souhaitons développer
l'apprentissage transfrontalier c'est le
but de opération deuxième
témoignage quand on quand on travaille
avec nos partenaires allemands
on voit bien que nous souhaitons prend
particulier développer l'apprentissage
est l'apprentissage transfrontalier pour
le post bac notamment pas uniquement
sinon monsieur beige clair va faire les
gros yeux mais notamment l'apprentissage
post bac et on voit bien que là il ya
une différence aussi peut-être pas
culturelle mais meda proches c'est que
nous on pense formation et en fait on a
en face de nous des partenaires qui
pensent projet d'entreprise
troisième témoignage est bien dans le
cas dans le cadre de la de la
préparation du congrès parti qui aura
lieu donc en décembre le 12e si je ne me
trompe pas eh bien nous préparons une
mise à jour des comparaisons des
systèmes suisse allemand français qui
sont pas toujours si éloigné que cela
est donc je donne cette information
c'est un document qui sera à disposition
de de tous pour une meilleure
connaissance des dispositifs comparer et
et pour développer l'apprentissage
transformer transfrontalier vous
comprendrez que pour nous c'est
important
merci merci de votre témoignage s'il ya
un petit les jeunes sont pas beaucoup
exprimé à part vous qui l'avez fait très
clairement et très bien à voilà un jeune
homme qui veut bien nous apporter un
petit peu son son témoignage ou sa
question alesi comme ça vous serez aussi
représente vous allez très bien
représenté dans cette table ronde mais
il n'y avait pas de raison que vous ne
puissiez pas parler ce sera d'ailleurs
la dernière question je crois là parce
que le temps avance mais allez-y
merci de vous lever qu'on voit mieux de
vous présenter bonjour à tous donc
aurélien et non je voulais poser une
question pour des êtres en apprentissage
oui je suis sage
o au cfa de l'argentique de pays de la
loire c'est dans quel domaine tapissier
en sièges
d'accord allez-y donc oui je sais tu es
à propos du secteur métiers d'art j'ai
vu beaucoup d'apprentis très motivés ou
en tout cas de deux jeunes qui venaient
pour un apprentissage qui étaient très
motivés et qu'ils avaient du mal à
trouver un patron parce qu'on sait très
bien que
c'est c'est un métier ce sont des
métiers à ces jolis seins il ya
l'ébénisterie tapisserie vitrail
d'horreur encadreurs et les jeunes sont
motivés
enfin ils paraissent motivés et ils
n'arrivent pas trouvé d'employeur
comment faire pour motiver ses
employeurs et leur donner envie de
prendre des apprentis alors vaste vaste
question mais c'est important monsieur
baechler peut-être vous qui êtes
employeur artisans impasse comment
est-ce qu'on peut encourager et
finalement aussi les patrons à recruter
des apprentis
parce qu on en revient toujours là s'ils
sont pas là il y aura pas d'apprentis ça
oui alors c'est un mot parce qu'on a vu
et non en un mot c'est particulièrement
une difficulté dans dans le domaine et
si le jeune homme est là il a posé la
question
c'est vraiment que c'est une vraie
question malheureusement d'habitude j'ai
toujours une vraie réponse
mais là je suis ok alors sans beach
hockey mais jean patrick farrow kia va
vous aidez moi je dirai simplement une
chose parce qu'il faut quand même
essayer de terminer sur une note
positive
je dirais simplement une chose quand
vous regardez les professions justement
de la boulangerie ou dans les métiers de
bouche
la boucherie et cetera vous avez des
professions qui ont réfléchi
l'évolution de leur image et à se re
montrer de façon attractive par rapport
à l'évolution des entreprises je pense
qu'il ya un travail à faire dans dans la
profession par rapport à l'image au
courant d'affaires et aux perspectives
d'avenir on a trop souvent
malheureusement dans ces entreprises des
gens qui ce centre qui se replient sur
eux-mêmes et qu'ils se sentent un peu
agressé dans un environnement qui leur
paraît pas porter alors qu'il ya une
vraie demande et que cette demande n'est
pas n'est pas satisfaite josy c'est
juste un exemple justement il est au
centre de formation d'apprentis qui est
en baisse dans la région dont vient
monsieur wauquiez
ce centre de formation qui travaille sur
les baies mystery travail
la restauration de meubles du château
dans l'environnement qui permet de
travailler à la fois au maintien du
patrimoine et qui donne
et un sens à cet apprentissage qui est
fait d'un mot jean-claude car oui je
dirais jeune homme qui est tapissier un
siège qu'il aura sûrement des débouchés
au sénat non je ne sais pas très bien
vous regardez il ya plein de taille de
fauteuils aux différents d'ailleurs dans
l'hémicycle nous avons été sensibles à
ce problème et nous avons inscrit là
aussi dans la loi une disposition qui
permet aux jeunes d'avoir deux mois
supplémentaires dès qu'ils ont trouvé un
cfa pour pouvoir trouver une entreprise
donc c'est pas c'est pas négligeable
c'est un vrai problème nous avons pris
en compte un obstacle à surmonter le mot
de la fin peut-être pour monsieur je
parte je voudrais poser la question
suivante
vous avez vu beaucoup de responsables
français de jeunes qui s'intéressait à
ce qui se passait en allemagne
est-ce que vous il ya des choses qui en
france vous intéresse vous dites ah bah
tiens c'est bien on pourrait s'en
inspirer aussi je pense que là j'ai
toujours eu l'impression que le système
d'enseignement dans les écoles est
beaucoup plus efficace comme allemagne
je sais qu'il ya toujours des choses
qu'on peut améliorer mais on a une âme
en allemagne on a une crise du système
d'enseignement et je crois que on a on
peut beaucoup apprendre de la france sur
ce sujet et je pense que ce que la
plusieurs personnes handi l'importance
de la mobilité c'est pas seulement
importante pour pour que pour qu'on se
déplace pour faire
pour travailler dans notre pays mais
c'est aussi pour important pour acquérir
des compétences interculturelles et
c'est un moment important je suis très
heureux qu'on fait un point ce n'est sur
la mobilité et qui a beaucoup d'être sûr
ça puisque ça c'est l'avenir
pour ça je pense juste très heureux
quand on n'a plus cette des barons
ensemble franco allemande
je crois c'est toujours très fructueux
merci en tout cas merci merci à tous
ceux de réponse voilà malheureusement on
doit terminer ce moment des chances qui
j'espère vous aura un petit peu mieux
appris le fonctionnement de
l'apprentissage en allemagne bien sûr
mais aussi en france on en a vu à la
fois les obstacles aujourd'hui mais
aussi les perspectives notamment grâce à
vous nicolas et patrick on vous remercie
particulièrement merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi